malheureusement les gens sont tristes
voyez ils se promènent ils sont là comme
des des morts vivants vous savez qu'en
fait c'est dur amuser les gens
croyez-moi c'est vraiment
[Musique]
dur dans le code de police au titre 5e
etantentré à l'ordre et à la sûreté
publique au chapitre 1er section 3
saltin ban joueur d'or chanteur ambulant
ordonnance du 3 avril 1828 à l'article
998 il est dit à daté de 8 jours après
la publication de la présente ordonnance
aucun individu ne pourra exercer le
métier de saltinban dans les rues et
places publiques de Paris ou des
communes rurales du ressort de la
préfecture de police sans en avoir
obtenu de nous la permission laquelle
sera visée tous les 6 mois et renouvelée
tous les ans à l'article 2004 il est dit
nul ne pourra à moins d'une autorisation
spéciale rassembler les passants au son
de la caisse ou de la TR
sous peine d'être privé de sa
permission malgré ses interdits il est
une race d'individu pour qu'il a liberté
d'être conditionne toute leur vie
liberté d'aller o mène leur pas vendre
des illusions donner du rêve rencontrer
un publicque râur au complice qui selon
donnera un
[Musique]
S
et bien je joue dans les rues pour
gagner un peu notre vie puisque de toute
façon c'est la seule chose qu'on puisse
faire apparemment pour gagner notre vie
dans ce métier là je comprends et puis
bien peutêtre poursuivre un peu
jeanclaud parce que c'est lui qui m'a
inié à
ça
[Musique]
contour
j'ai vu non
j'ai la manche puis maintenant ça va
faire à peu près 6 ans 6 ans je la
manche je trouve que c'est certainement
plus intéressant de d'être connu enfin
de travailler disons d'avoir des galas
bien bien attitrés plutôt que de
travailler dans la rue enfin il est
certain qu'on a moins de contact humain
en faisant en chantant dans un théâtre
qu'en chantant dans la R mais ça va bien
chanter la rue j'aimerais quand même
[Musique]
changer les G AC parce que là on est
jeune physiquement on fait jeune et tout
mais les années pass et toutpr onetrouve
faire la manche à 40 ans ou 50
ans
c'estjà plus dur
parce Lesens c'est quelqu'un qui a pas
aussi dans la vie que je sais pas moi je
préfère chanter dans la rue et gagner 10
fois moins qu' allant travailler ENF
travailler naturellement c'est enfin
c'est un travail ce qu'on fait mais
disons qu'on travaille 2 he ou 3 He par
jour donc ça nous laisse ça nous laisse
le temps de vivre que nous on a réto par
exemple pour faire ça il nous faut moins
200 chansons et puis t tous les mois
faut monter des nouvelles chansons pour
per aux
gens les gens croient que on arrive
comme ça puis ça y est on travaille pas
alors que ça demande pour une chanson
faut compter déjà au moins 3 semaines de
répétition pour que je soit en place
j'ai dit en veux-tu aux hommes pour ce
qu'ils t'ont
fait il dit par d'amour pas de haine
pour toute la race humaine je lui ai dit
et maintenant qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire je travaillerai la terre et ferai
des prières je suis orelin je suis
seulement de
passage triste heure voyage dans ce
monde en rage dites-leur bien je suis
seulement de
[Musique]
passage l'accordéon pour moi c'est un
c'est c'est un compagnon pour moi un
accordéon et quand je joue de
l'accordéon je joue quand je veux et je
fais ce que je veux je veux jouer 2h 3h
je joue 2 3h je veux jouer une journée
je joue une journée et mon accordéon
c'est c'est une compagnon moi j'appelle
pas ça la mandé cité parce que on fait
un travail on joue de l'accordéon on
fait quelque chose on dialogue avec les
personnes donc on tend pas la main mais
moi je ne demande rien je mets donc une
assiette à côté de mon accordéon donne
qui veut qui peut et je ne demande
absolument rien alors donc j'estime que
ce n'est pas la mendicité et ni la
mendicité déguisée comme la police ils
ont l'air d'insinuer ils ont qu'à
arrêter les voleurs ils ont ils ont qu'à
il y a des voleurs il y a des bandits
fait mieux d'arrêter les bandits un pau
type qui va jouer de l'accordéon il fait
pas de mal au contraire ça distrait les
[Musique]
gens
on est comme les hondelles on revient au
printemps c'està-dire que c'estàd qu'on
se retrouve au hasard suivant les
circonstances suivant les libertés de
chacun et justement ça détermine un peu
le style de musique qu'on va jouer
suivant les instruments qu'on arrive à à
dégoter pour le jour
même suivant l'humeur le temps on va se
faire bronzer au Flor ou à la contresc
ou n'importe où en faisant de la
musique et très souvent d'ailleurs c'est
c'est des gens simples enfin d' d'un
milieu pas forcément superisé qui se
sentent beaucoup plus proche de nous et
qui qui donnent des pièces de 5 francs
des billets de 1000 et
cetera
l'amendicité pour moi est j'allais dire
gratuite enfin disons c'est c'est le
type qui qui vient de taper qui dit tap
pas 100
balles je JIS dans la rue parce que
parce que c'est chouette
parce que j'aime bien parce que c'est il
y a un public il y a une ambiance il y a
un contact il y a une gé et puis
également parce
que pour la liberté aussi quand il y a
pas les flics et puis de toute façon
c'est jamais désagréable d'avoir un peu
de r en poche ça ça ça fait toujours du
bien je crois à tout le
monde 1 2 1
2 comm pas commence pas ha d
[Musique]
ha
j'ai trouvé j'ai envie de faire du
spectacle maintenant j'ai ça fait un an
que je travaille le
MIM en ce moment je travaille l'automate
parce que ça ça m'intéresse ça
m'intéresse ça c'est joli ça
c'est je changerai sûrement je fer autre
chose je le fais dans la rue parce que
c'est un endroit c'est le seul endroit
où les gens viennent ils passent par là
les gens s'ennuient sûrement en rentrant
du boulot il rentrent chez eux ils
s'ennuient et puis ils ont besoin de
voir quelque chose ils en a
envie si ouais je les emmène un peu dans
un petit dans un petit un petit monde
pour un quart d'heure enfin ça c'est
extraordinaire bon ils sont assez
émerveillés ils sont étonnés
quand je me maquille je pense à mon
maquillage je regarde bon je suis assez
différent de naturellement je me regarde
dans la glace un peu comme quelqu'un
d'autre c'est
évident et puis ensuite je prends le
métro alors là on me regarde c'est plus
moi qui me regarde et j'arrive à à la
contreescarpe ou ENF un peu à mon marre
à d'autres
endroits et là j'attends je regarde les
gens bon il se cré une espèce
d'atmosphère autour dans la rue les gens
regardent un peu puis quand je sens que
ça va bien sans prévenir personne je me
même je me surprends un peu craque je
pars comme ça en automate bon ça vient
vraiment
naturellement la police a des ordres de
d'empêcher tout tout spectacle dans la
rue alors que c'est un endroit où les
gens viennent se promener pour voir un
spectacle pour auss une promenade donc
euh il nous demande d'abord de pas faire
de musique il nous demande de partir moi
j'aiété arrêté la dernière fois parce
que je faisais de la musique bon j'ai
une petite boîte à musique qui fait
vraiment pas beaucoup de bruit enfin
c'est vraiment un exercice de mim donc
est tout à fait silencieux j'éta j'étais
en on m'a demandé de partir pour ta page
[Musique]
nocturne
la musique que l'on joue c'est une
musique qui vient d'Iran et des environs
de l'Iran pourquoi on joue dans la rue
d'abord parce que je crois que c'est le
seul moyen de de faire écouter aux gens
ce qu'on a envie de leur faire écouter
exactement l'stant créatif se perd
complètement actuellement et c'est ça
qui est intéressant dans la aussi dans
la musique dans la rue si vous voulez
c'est pas maintenant il y a évidemment
le point de vue de la mendicité la
mendicité c'est on on nous a déjà arrêté
emmené au poste de police et pour
mendicité on nous a fait une fiche une
belle fiche IBM et tout mais comme des
mendiants quoi absolument on est
absolument rien des train savate on nous
a fouillé de partout on est des
c'est-à-dire que on est là et on
correspond pas aux norme au canon de la
société on fait quelque chose qui est un
peu en dehors que les les gens eux-mêmes
le sentent les gens eux-mêmes ont un peu
peur quand on joue parfois on le sent
très bien ils aimeraient venir là
montrer qu'ils aiment ça mettre leurs
pièces dans leur chapeau mais au fond
ils se disent annon c'est pas vrai ça
c'est pas de l'art parce que l'art c'est
à 8h30 à la télé voilà ce qu'ils se
[Musique]
disent
avant de de jouer dans l'ORD de barbarie
j'ai fait un peu tous les métiers avant
de venir à l'animation de de la rue qui
a changé complètement d'ailleurs le le
rythme de mon
existence la rue c'est vraiment
l'univers dans lequel je me sens le
mieux parce
que parce que on est rcontre toutes
sortes de gens des gens
simples comme des gens qui se qui
pensent tout
connaître et puis il y a qu'une seule
chose qui compte actuellement dans cette
société dans la rue surtout c'est le
fric et le fric c'est la
violence le droit de
danser
[Musique]
[Rires]
allons-y pour que la rue de la
République devienne la rue de la Liberté
préparons la monnaie s'il vous
plaît vous pas
de
[Musique]
FA
la magie dans la rue c'est pas
sophistiqué c'est vrai tout le monde
peut participer de 7 à 77 ans c'est
comme tintinou
ça mais là il y a les enfants il y a
tout le monde ça fait vraiment plaisir
parce
que le plus pire c'est les gosses quoi
son le plus terrible parce queà chaque
fois bon il y en a qui découvrent le
truc bon ils sont très dur avec moi mais
ça me plaît
quoi va pasarder à commencer comme j'ai
pas jamais Pison eu de chance c'est
malheureux à dire jamais eu de chance
bon ben ça fait rien je me contente du
trottoir et croyez-moi ça fait 11 ans
que je fais le trottoir et ça me plaît
quoi ça me plaît
quoi je suis vraiment en contact avec le
public
quoi parce que malheureusement les gens
sont tristes c'est vrai donc ils se
promènent ils sont tristes voyez ils se
promènent ils sont là comme des des
morts vivants que là bon ben bon j'
troup un petit une masse de monde 800
personnes de ce cours enfin pendant un
quart d'heure vraiment je je sens que
les gens sont vraiment bien quoi c'est
vrai vous savez qu'en fait c'est dur
amuser les gens croyez-moi c'est
vraiment
dur bon et ben vous savez quoi pas tard
à commencer monsieur monsieur est-ce qu'
est fendu en monsieur est-ce qu' est
fendu pas moi
l'anne non prenez comme ceci monsieur
vous les prenezz pas par l'intérieur
vous avez compris on les prend on les
passe par l'intérieur on soir
munique
je je suis
l'inventeur possesseur de ce truc tiens
monsieur bonsoir Monsieur Je de
connaissance je me présente je m'appelle
Riquet n'ay pas peur Monsieur Je un
avant
d'agir monsieur est-ce que vous fait
cadeau votre petit bout Dereux don petit
B
merci bien vous gentil tout le monde est
gentil monsieur oh là là tout simplement
je attaché deux morceaux c'est pas les
deux morce je faire le papillon guise
souvenir il pas je pas le papillon hein
tiens les P cravate il do la goûte de
poire et pas manger le dessert ça tombe
bien et voilà la cravate
RTU ça vous fait plaisir monsieur un
très joli petit de papillon merci bien
merci bien merci
bien merci bien monsieur merci bien
mercine qui veux don pe peu c'est ça que
je leur dis mais faut pas que ça retire
la nourriture d'un
nourrissonin c'est normal ça c'est
normal je vois je vois des gens qui
donne pas enfin qu'est-ce qui met en
colère c'est donc les gens qui me
donnent généreusement 5 centimes
remarquez je le fais remarqueer je dis
je vouis que je vous rende la monnaie
non c'est ça qui a
bien est je repasse pour les gens qui
sertoublés pas t'en préparer vous savez
ça va tout le
monde ça y est ça y est personne oublié
et à 3 la CR garanti au glouton la CR
cons comme ça elle était j'ppelle le
petit B souvenir vous êtes prêt à 3
1 2 2 et demi 2 3/4 je me présente je
m'appelle
Riquet
et ah oui on peut Lapp la mérité merci
[Musique]
bien